The Joe Rogan experience,
but then there's people like Hank Shaw who is a,
also a world famous chef who is also a hunter who prefers older animals cause he
thinks there's like there's flavor to them and there's life to them like that
they're,
they're aging and all their life experience,
it comes out if you cook them correctly,
it just requires a different sort of preparation.
All right.
It's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like a young women versus older women,
like young women have a lot of positives about them,
but older women have just as many positives about them.
Older women,
that flavor,
that's what you want,
right?
You want to check who's like,
yeah,
who didn't give a six plus,
who hits the gym every day.
Trust me,
I know.
I,
I've had this conversation about the whole life.
If we stop working out,
it's over.
I say if we stopped working for like we,
if we stop exercising and caring about our health,
it's all there.
It's over fact.
No,
I mean like I wanted to sign up.
I wanted my,
uh,
one of my lawyer as a joke to sign a document that says if we,
if we get fat,
it's like a free and clear gone.
But I mean it,
if she gets fat out,
if I get that she should be out.
If either of us break this thing that we're doing together,
what if it brings you closer than we've met?
She gets fed up to worry about body image anymore.
Fuck you.
Just let yourself go.
Fuck that.
Come on.
Fuck that shit.
Hey,
hey.
Hey shaming right now when you realize it or not.
I am.
I know you don't want to see him
show you fat.
Fuck.
I can't believe you.
I just think,
I think we've made a bond together.
We made a pact.
We were like,
we both want to stay relatively healthy and take care of ourselves.
So in our older years,
like my parents are both in really great shape because they've cared their whole
lives.
Not to a point of like,
you know,
not having fun.
They still have a great fucking time,
but no,
but just they just stayed consistent with like caring about what you put in your
body and the way you work.
Yes.
Simple Shit.
So yeah,
if she gets fat by,
if I get that she's by two,
if I get fucking fat,
she's gone.
She even said it.
She was like,
I'll leave your fat ass being fat.
It's such a weird one that people call people fat who aren't fat.
Right.
I need to fucking know.
But I'm just saying like as an insult.
It's such a weird one.
It is because like girls will call girls fat.
Like that fat bitch look at her like you're not fat.
No.
What he's saying,
it's just,
it's a dig.
It's another gift for you.
You Fat.
Fuck.
Like guys will say that the guys that like barely have any fat on bed.
Fuck you to know their cheeseburger.
Jamie,
you fed fuck.
Fuck that it,
it's an easy day.
Yeah.
It's an easy insult to the how to grow.
Call me fat at the comp.
There's a video of it online who grow calling me fat at the comedy store in a
pull up.
My recently my six pack,
no wait long time now it looks like you're just crazy,
but it was like,
why am I fat?
Like what?
Where are you coming up with that?
You're fucking,
you're fat.
I bet you're we,
it's weird the the,
the fact that the body can carry excess tissue.
Yeah.
It's a mistake.
Like I get it.
It's a good way to store fuel and when it gets to a point like why are you still
hungry?
What kind of Shitty do we have that you're this big and you're still hungry.
You should say,
hey bro,
bro,
bro Bro,
stop.
We got the fuel.
But it does not put to your body's working off carbohydrates.
That's a problem and it's not burning fat.
That's why that whole Keto genic diet works as much as people don't like to
think that it does.
There's so much controversy about that like from non scientists,
which is hilarious.
Have you talked to actual scientists like Dom D'agostino who talked to you about
the peer reviewed research?
That's been done on ketogenic states and all the different benefits and what you
know and how it can be healthy and how he does it and Ketone esters and all
these different factors you have to take into consideration the ketone testing
and blood testing it.
There's all these knuckleheads saying it's bad for you.
It's not a good idea.
Like Julian Michael's like it's not a good idea.
It's not good.
You better stop.
They say that as a benefit.
Seven pounds,
right?
It's a normal state.
It's a normal state for your body to burn fat and you have more clarity and
you'll also,
you're not as hungry.
You're not as hungry during the day.
My,
my problem with it is I don't think it's the best thing for performance.
I think like you have a little bit more energy if he,
you burn glucose too.
Cause even like the top,
uh,
there's uh,
Zack bitter.
He wouldn't even when the American hero brand 20,
he ran a hundred miles in like 11 hours around a track.
These guys that could do this shit.
It was some crazy record.
Two miles and I need to chill for a minute.
Some crazy,
some crazy record for a hundred mile record.
He broke a 11 hours,
40 minutes or seconds.
That's insane that I met a mild,
say seven minutes and I'll smile hundred fucking miles.
Now he is on primarily a carnivore diet.
All meat,
all meat.
Rib-Eyes barely,
barely any meat and fat,
barely any Greens,
right?
Barely any greens.
But then when he competes,
he takes a lot of glucose.
Like he'll take like Glucose Gel,
like those gels,
Gel packets,
those runners use,
he pounds in that shed pounds in the carbs.
So he could burn that off too.
Right.
You know,
cause he's living off for like fat and protein.
But when he competes,
he doesn't do that.
And the thing,
I think that's the key.
You're saying when he competes,
he does use the glucose.
But when he's done competing,
he doesn't fucking,
he goes back to putting his body into a fat burning state.